so Evolution could if we wanted to
construct an organism that's able to
perceive the flow of blood through your
body the way you see an old friend and
say yo what's up how's the wife and the
kids uh in that same way you would see
that you would feel like a connection to
the liver yeah yeah I think you know
maybe other people's liver no just your
own because you don't have access to
other people's lives not yet but you
could imagine some really interesting
connections right but like sexual
selection like oh that girl's got a nice
liver well that's like the the way her
blood flows the the Dynamics of the
blood
is very interesting it's novel I've
never seen one of those but you know
that's that's exactly what we're trying
to half-ass when we when we um uh judge
Judgment of beauty by facial Symmetry
and so on that's that's a half-assed
assessment of exactly that of exactly
that because if your sales could not
cooperate enough to keep your your
organism symmetrical yeah you know you
can make some inferences about what else
is wrong right like that's a that's a
very you know that's a very basic
interesting yeah so that in some deep
sense actually that is what we're doing
where
trying to infer
how
the health we use the word healthy but
basically how functional is this
biological system I'm looking at so I
can con hook up with that one and make
Offspring yeah yeah well what kind of
Hardware might their genomics give me
that that might be useful in the future
I wonder why Evolution didn't give us
um higher resolution signal like why the
whole peacock thing with the feathers it
doesn't seem
the very little bandwidth signal for
sexual selection I'm gonna and I'm not
an expert on on this stuff but on
peacocks well you know no you know but
but I'll take a stab at the reason I
think that it's because it's an arms
race you see you don't want everybody to
know everything about you so I think
that as much as as much as and in fact
there's another interesting part of this
arms race which is
if you think about this uh the the most
adaptive evolvable system is one that
has the most level of top-down control
right if it's really easy to say to a
bunch of cells make another finger
versus okay here's 10 000 gene
expression changes that you need to do
to make it to change your finger right
the the the the the system with good
top-down control that has memory and we
need to get back to that by the way
that's a question I neglected to answer
about where the memory is and so on
um a system that uses all of that is
really highly evolvable and that's
fantastic but guess what it's also
highly um subject to hijacking by
parasites by uh by by by cheaters of
various kinds by con specifics like we
we found that um and then that that goes
back to the story of the pattern memory
these in these planaria there's a
bacterium that lives on these planaria
that bacterium has an input into how
many heads the worm is going to have
because it's hijacks that that control
system and it's able to make a chemical
that basically interfaces with the
system that calculates how many heads
you're supposed to have oven they can
have to and they can make them have two
heads and so you can imagine that if you
are two so you want to be understandable
for your own parts to understand each
other but you don't want to be too
understandable because you'll be too
easily controllable and so I think that
that my guess is that that
um that that that that opposing pressure
keeps this from being a super high
bandwidth kind of thing where we can
just look at somebody and know know
everything about them so it's a kind of
biological game of Texas Hold'em yeah
he's showing some cards and you're
hiding other cards and that's part of it
and there's bluffing and there's and all
that and then there's probably whole
species that would do way too much
bluffing that's probably where peacocks
fall I am there's a there's a book
that I don't remember if I read or if I
if I wrote If I read summaries of the
book but it's about the evolution of
beauty and birds where is that from is
that a book or does Richard Dawkins talk
about it but basically there's some
species start to like over select for
beauty not over select they just some
reason select for beauty there is a case
to be made actually now I'm starting to
remember I think Darwin himself made a
case that you can select based on beauty
alone
so yeah that beauty there's a point
where B it doesn't represent some
underlying biological truth you start to
select for for beauty itself and I think
the the Deep question is there is some
if is there some evolutionary value to
Beauty but that's an interesting kind of
thought that this
can we deviate completely from the deep
biological truth to actually appreciate
some kind of the the summarization in
itself